on va passer au débat de ce club on va
parler immigration on donne la parole au
bérichon de ce plateau qutin on va
parler d'un revers pour les républicains
puisqueil y a des textes qui sont
examinés sur l'immigration en ce moment
revers pour les républicains à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat voilà
depuis mai dernier lesr effectivementian
porte une proposition de modification de
la Constitution le texte contient h
articles mais deux mesures font
particulièrement polémique d'ailleurs
vous en parliez avec Patrick stéphanini
juste avant par exemple il y a ce
référendum élargi aux questions
relatives à l'entrée et au séjour des
étrangers en France et au droit de la
nationalité c'est l'article 2 de cette
proposition de modification de la
Constitution également le fait
d'autoriser la France à déroger aux
règles européennes afin d'assurer je
cite le respect de l'identité
constitutionnelle de la France ou la
sauvegarde des intérêts fondamentaux de
la nation c'est l'article 3 cette
semaine cette proposition été examinée
au Sénat en commission et à l'Assemblée
nationale en séance c'est un échec pour
le texte dans les deux chambres on
commence par laquelle oh le Sénat allez
c'est parti on va évoquer le Sénat alors
norm yes au Sénat on a assisté à je cite
un désaccord majeur au sein de la
majorité sénatoriale de la droite et du
centre les centristes ont refusé de
voter les deux mesures phare que l'on
évoquait tout à l'heure les articles 2
et 3 sur le référendum et les
dérogations aux règles européennes déjà
on avait vu que pendant l'examen du
projet lo immigration il y avait un peu
de friture sur la ligne sur le texte il
a fallu attendre l'accord entre LR et UC
pour qu'on puisse vraiment avoir un
texte voté au Sénat écoutez pardon on va
voir effectivement que le ikv par
exemple un centriste nous a expliqué
pourquoi est-ce que les centristes
étaient étaient contre cette
modification cette idée d'lr nous heurte
àthliia Public Sénat lui préfère
travailler sur le dossier et sur ces
dossiers au Parlement européen à la
Commission au Conseil européen il
préfère travailler à l'intérieur des
instances européennes le texte devrait
donc être logiquement retoqué en séance
subir le même sort que lorsqu'il était
examiné en commission ce sera mardi
prochain le 12 décembre Rian on va
passer à l'Assemblée mais un mot juste
là-dessus Frédéric arneud sur ces
divisions au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale euh que provoque ce texte
sur l'immigration bah j'ai envie de dire
elles viennent de très très loin euh
voilà je vais pas je suis pas comme vous
euh spécialiste de ce projet de loi euh
fait immigration mais ça me fait
furieusement penser à 7 mois des
élections européennes au tiraillement
jadis dans les années 80 90 entre le RPR
et l'UDF une UDF allez RV Marseille est
un héritier de l'UDF Union centriste qui
est pro européenne et voilà et qui ne
qui ne peut pas accepter l'article 3
c'est absolument impossible pour un
centriste européen héritier de Simon
veille de ces de ces grands courants
centristes et un RPR um LR où il y a ces
tiraillement sur la question européenne
ou o le comment dire l'adhésion
européenne a connu si je puis dire des
véritables fractures lors de Maastricht
ce gin pasqui lors du référendum de 2005
et donc c'est vrai que
quand la majorité c'estatorial LR seul
veut porter cet artile 3 ça crée cette
division je parle même pas de ce qui se
passe au S mais même au sein du peuple
de droite c'est pas quelque chose qui va
être consensuel alors que beaucoup de
projets de loi on l'a vu ensemble il y a
quelques semaines sur ce projet de loi
immigration sont extrêmement consensuels
et sont soutenus par l'ensemble des
Français ouais arud c'est vrai que c'est
c'est un clivage hein le fait que les
républicains veuillent la primuté du
droit national sur le droit européen ça
passe pas chez les centrés il y a un
clivage sur cette question européenne
entre il y a un clivage politique dont
Frédéric a rappelé l'historique depuis
maintenant près de 40 ans entre en effet
une aile qui est plutôt souverainiste et
puis une aile qui est libérale
européenne centriste ça existe même de
ça existait même avant les déjà dans les
années 70 donc si vous voulez ça remonte
en effet à à très loin ensuite bon il
faut essayer de comprendre la stratégie
des républicain la stratégie des
républicains c'est de prendre date et où
là peut-être j'ai une petite différence
avec Frédéric oui certes l'opinion
publique valide les mesures de Gérald de
d'armanin dans son projet de loi elle
valide surtout les mesures les plus
fermes en l'occurrence ça c'est ça qui
est le plus important mais
vraisemblablement elle juge aussi que
l'on ne va pas assez loin dans la
reprise en main de notre politique
migratoire donc c'est d'une certaine
manière pour les LR une façon parce que
je pense qu'ils étaient assez conscients
de la difficulté quand même à faire
adopter leur proposition c'est d'une
certaine manière pour
eux la une façon de prendre date
vis-à-vis de l'opinion et puis surtout
d'éviter une hémorragie supplémentaire
de ce qui leur reste comme électorat
vers le rassemblement national mais
indéiablement aussi ça traduit au sein
de la majorité sénatoriale des
tiraillements que l'on avait vu sur
d'autres textes d'ailleurs que sur le
texte sur l'immigration mais enfin qu'on
a vu encore de manière plus forte lors
du lors de la discussion du texte sur
l'immigration quoi qu'ils se sont quand
même mis d'accord donc ça dit qu'en
effet il y a des tiraillement au sein de
cette majorité sénatoriale ouais on va
parler justement Frédéric he de
l'opinion sur l'immigration mais pour
poursuivre parce que alors ça sera
examiné mardi en séance au Sénat on a vu
que ça a été compliqué en commission
mais ce texte il était examiné hier par
les députés
voilà justement C proposition de loi
était effectivement inscrite dans ce
qu'on appelle la niche c'estàd le le
l'ordre du jour réservé aur
effectivement hier à l'Assemblée
nationale effectivement dès le départ
Gérald daranin lui et bien il a fustigé
le texte venu de la droite à la tribune
de l'Assemblée nationale il a dit la
promesse que vous faites à travers
l'adoption de ces huit articles
reprendre le contrôle sur notre
politique migratoire pose un certain
nombre de problèmes il a continué plus
tard votre proposition de loi propose de
rompre avec notre tradition
constitutionnelle et bouleverser
l'ensemble des équilibres
institutionnels excusez du peu c'est
sans doute ce qui a poussé la commission
des Lois du Sénat à supprimer ses
articles hier il a donc fait lui-même
référence à ce qui se jouait au Sénat au
même moment donc l'examen hier avait
commencé vers 11h le matin rien ne s'est
passé comme les Hur le voulaient
multiplication d'amendements de la
gauche vote pour supprimer des articles
et à 20h Olivier marlex le chef de fil
des députés a pris acte et a mis fin à
l'examen du texte en retirant le texte
et il a dit à ce moment-là nous
débattons depuis maintenant 8h et depuis
8h nous avons vu dans l'hémicycle se
constituer une majorité en l'occurrence
avec effectivement la gauche et la le
groupe renaissance pour défaire
détricoter savamment tranquillement le
texte immigration voté par le Sénat qui
il a fait une référence au fait que
c'est exactement ce qui sétait joué
effectivement en commission la semaine
dernière et euh effectivement euh de son
côté Gérald haranin lui il avait parlé
d'un double frexit européen
constitutionnel l'ambiance était très
tendue en séance avec un même un député
insoumis Antoine léomand qui a dit la
France s'est assis à la table des
vainqueurs en 1944 grâce à une bonne
partie des combattants du Maghreb grâce
à ceux qui ont débarqué sur notre patrie
pour la libérer des nazis de ceux qui
sont en face aujourd'hui il là il a
pointé vers le rassemblement national il
y a eu une Bron vers le rassemblement
national il y a une gronka dans
l'hémicycle il a dit voilà les apports
positifs de l'immigration dans un Chahu
général vous avez là les descendants de
Vichy et il a dit vous avez ici les
combattants de la liberté donc à
l'Assemblée nationale les débats d'hier
en fait on comprend c'était un tour de
chauffe avant l'arrivée du projet de loi
immigration lundi en séance en tout cas
ce qu'on peut dire aussi sur le plan
politique c'est que c'est bien un revers
pour les républicains la séquence cette
semaine entre désunions avec l'alliés
centriste au Sénat et échec de sa
proposition à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est un revert pour l'aler oui alors
maintenant la scène parlementaire n'est
pas une scène très visible par les
français même si on va le voir le le
projet de loi a quand même été discuté
dans les conversations des Français par
4atre Français sur 10 et notamment plus
que la moyenne les personnes âgées les
retraités et les sympathisants LR il y a
une attente et je partage complètement
ce qu' a dire rano fait tout à l'heure
une attente du peuple de droite sur la
reprise de contrôle l'immigration quand
les Français on on l' fait parler
spontanément c'est une perte de maîtrise
d'autorité de l'État donc donc
dans ce CRE là collé bien avec une
partie des aspirations des Français
maintenant c'est vra que ce double échec
et ben signe une fois de plus le
problème de positionnement et d'espace
pour les républicains j'ai tendance
souvent à résumer le champ politique en
une guerre des trois blocs ce bloc nupes
très fracturé ce bloc reconquête Ren ce
bloc central où est LR our et c'est vrai
que sur cette question là on a vu une en
fait alliance qui n'en est absolument
pas une mais une plutôt un contre du
avec d'un côté la gauche et de l'autre
la majorité mais est-ce que c'est c'est
un échec pour les lair ou est-ce que
c'est une manière d'apparaître ferme sur
cette question de l'immigration sur
laquelle les Français attendent de la
fermeté d'abord je partage ce que vient
de dire Frédéric c'est-à-dire que je ne
suis pas sûr que l'exposition vis-à-vis
de l'opinion de ces débats soit très
forte les en effet forte pour nous qui
commentons cette
actualité et bien sûr les gens qui
regarde mais ensuite ce qui est
important c'est qu'en effet moi je pense
que LR n'a pas finalement d'autre
solution que la solution qui est en
effet d'avoir un discours de fermeté et
de dirsissement notamment vis-à-vis de
cette question de la souveraineté parce
que c'est le nœud gourien de tous les
débats politiques à mon
avis passer mais aussi avenir parce
qu'en fin de compte quand monsieur
Darmanin dit c'est notre tradition
constitutionnelle désolé c'est une
tradition constitutionnelle récente la
supériorité de la norme européenne sur
la norme nationale ça c'est c'est c'est
pas quelque chose qui est inscrit dans
l'histoire constitutionnelle profonde du
pays et ce qui est sûr c'est que quand
même les LR en l'occurrence essayent de
finalement de développer une stratégie
et un discours qui à leurs yeux est ce
qu'attendent une partie de leur électeur
et une grande partie de l'opinion
publique donc de ce point de vuelà dans
le dans la relation à l'opinion moi je
ne suis pas sûr que ça soit un échec
pour eux mais la réalité le problème
c'est que ils sont difficilement
audibles ils sont difficilement audibles
parce que l'espace politique qui est le
leur est un espace qui est extrêmement
restreint depuis 2017 ils n'ont pas
résolu leur problème finalement d'offre
politique et d'incarnation de cette
offre politique ils sont pris dans une
sorte de tenaille entre une partie de la
macronie qui est une finalement qui a
récupérer ce bloc dont on parlait tout à
l'heure qui est le bloc UDF libéral
alors pas tous mais enfin une grosse
partie de ce bloc et puis et puis le le
le rassemblement national il y a eu un
deuxième échec euh il faut le rappeler
aussi lors de la discussion de cette
niche parlementaire LR hier c'est
notamment la proposition que le groupe
LR défendit de remettre en question
l'accord franco-algérien de
1968 et d'ailleurs on peut s'interroger
des conditions favorables au ressortis
dire qu'en fait vous avez aujourd'hui un
tiers de l'immigration un tiers de
l'immigration française et l'immigration
qui arrive en France est à peu près
un/ers ce sont ce sont à peu près un/ers
d'Algériens donc c'est quand même pas
négligeable en effet dans les flux
migratoires c'est même très important
donc cette proposition a été rejetée ce
qu'il faut noter c'est qu'elle aurait pu
être adoptée elle aurait pu être adoptée
mais moi ce que j'ai noté en regardant
le décompte des votes c'est qu'il il
manquait la moitié des parlementaires RN
dont Marine Le Pen qui ne sont pas allés
voter cette proposition de lo on peut
s'étonner quand même que le
rassemblement national qui se veut le
Fire de lance de la repr
la politique migratoire ne se soit pas
mobilisé sur un texte qui allait plutôt
dans le sens ouais parce que
effectivement pardon je la parole Fréd
non mais c'est un texte qui était
soutenu par lesaler évidemment par le
rassemblement national et par horizon
alors une partie d'horizon à voté
horizon à voé et même deux députés
macronistes on ont voté mais on parlait
tout à l'heure des divisions de la
majorité sénatoriale là on est dans les
divisions de la majorité présidentielle
son cette question de l'immigration ou
clairement c'est il y a vraiment de
lignes alors c'est vrai que ce texte en
plus de remise en cause d'accord Franco
algérien est soutenu massivement par les
Français une enquête syphope du mois de
septembre donné de mémoire 78 % des
Français favorable à une remise en cause
de cet accord pourquoi parce qu'il est
vu comme un accord injuste pourquoi
privilégier telle immigration sur
l'autre et puis maintenant bien sûr
dépasser contenu du fait et il y a
encore une enquêteope qui est sortie il
a quelques jours où on a quasiment tr/4
des Français qui considèent qu'il y a
trop d'immigrés en France y compris une
majorité de sympathisant de gauche mais
c'est vrai que c'est une question
l'immigration où jouis une sorte de
paradoxe d'un côté on a une opinion
publique beaucoup moins clivé que par le
passé une partie importante des
sympathisants de gauche ont fait un
chemin sur le fait de maîtriser
davantage l'immigration mais qui peut
créer de véritables fractures du côté de
la majorité même si on parle de ce sujet
on vient de publier la semaine dernière
avec CELI de radio fiduciale une enquête
que l'on pose chaque année fin août
début septembre sur les préoccupations
les priorités des Français la lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine arrive
en 9e position ça ne veut pas dire que
c'est pas un qui compte mais il est
quand même moins prégnant pour les
Français que le TripTic santé pouvoir
d'achat inflation et s insécurité et on
le voit aussi dans les sujets de
conversation puisque vous publiez aussi
un baromètre des sujets de conversation
hebdomadaire oui toutit des Français
mensuel pardon c'est 10e position je
crois lo sur l'imigration 10 position
même si pour un texte pour un projet de
loi je trouve que 4 français sur 10 qui
en parle ce n'est absolument pas rien
mais il faut dire aussi quelque chose
les Français parlent pas en fait
d'immigration de manière détournée on
sait que désormais une majorité de
Français de nos compatriotes font un
lien entre insécurité et immigration
l'attentat récent du pont de biraca mais
est aussi une manière de réactiver cette
ce sentiment de perte de maîtrise sur la
question migratoire quandtin un mot vous
allez nous en parler dans la revue de
presse mais on va déjà en dire un mot
parce que Gérald ramanin il parle à ce
matin oui voilà c'est parce qu'il est
effectivement en déplacement aujourd'hui
à Nice et à Menton et le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui revient sur ce projet de
loi immigration il dit qu'il est prêt à
le durcir et donc on voit Nice Matin qui
qui parle aujourd'hui d'une opération
séduction visant les républicains avec
une mainentendu il dit ne pas vouloir
croire que les LR je cite choisiront la
politique du pire ou de
l'irresponsabilité il se dit également
ouvert à une discussion sur le
rétablissement du délit de séjour
irrégulier qui fait partie des ajouts du
Sénat sur le projet l'immigration que
les députés ont supprimé en commission
qui participe de ce détricotage que
dénonc les les all du Sénat quant à
l'aide médicale d'étageent termin avec
cela il dit d'un il parle d'un débat qui
pourrait revenir je cite à court terme
nous ne sommes pas fermés a-t-il ajouté
voilà Gérald Harin il va tendre la mainr
pas n'importe où à Nice sur les terres
d'ericti auelà de l'aspect symbolique en
effet qu' tiennent ses déclarations et
ses propos à
Nice dansce matin il a en fait deux
obstacles il a un premier obstacle dès
lundi le groupe écologiste va déposer
une motion de Roger du texte et quand on
est coute un certain nombre de
républicains ils ne se disent pas
totalement hostiles à voter cette motion
de rejet notamment monsieur marlex donc
cette motion de rejet alors on peut
penser que sera pas adoptée mais il y a
quand même une zone de risque donc on
imagine que le weekend va être quand
même un weekend de très grosse
tractation pour le
ministreintérieur si toutes les
oppositions se réuniste de toute façon
arithmétiquement c'est que la majorité
n'a pas la majorité à l'Assemblée ça
depuis le début donc le projet
immigration pour êtreéè et ben le le
projet le projet peut être rejeté de
premier jour alors soit il retourne au
Sénat soit il va en commission mixte
paritaire ou alors catastrophe des
catastrophes il est abandonné ce qui est
un échec monumental pour géralde
Darmanin donc il a quand même une petite
pression jusqu'à lundi sur cette
question et puis après il y a le
deuxième sujet c'est en effet c'est qui
se rend bien compte que la façon dont le
texte a été détricoté par la commission
des lois par rapport au textte qui a été
voté par le Sénat a très peu de à très
peu de chance de recevoir la sentiment
des quelques républicains qui pourrai le
voter notamment de ces 15 ou 17
parlementaires républicains qui a 15
jours au moment où le texte arrivé en
discussion au Commission des loi se
disait prêt à le voter à condition qu'il
ne s'éloigne pas trop de la mouture
initiale votée par le le Sénat ce n'est
plus du tout le cas aujourd'hui donc
dans le contexte actuel je ne vois pas
comment encore une fois Gérald daranin
peut faire adopter son texte sans passer
par le 493 donc si vous voulez il est
obligé quand même aujourd'hui d'essayer
de rééquilibrer un peu plus à droite le
texte tel qu'il est sorti de la
commission des lois il est sur une ligne
de crête qui est quand même assez
compliqué ça va être très intéressant à
suivre dans les semaines qui viennent et
au mois de janvier aussi et Frédéric
parce que les Français vous montrez dans
vos enquêtes ils attendent ce texte ils
attendent des mesures plus fermes sur
l'immigration du coup si ce texte échoue
et qui plus est dès le premier jour qui
aurait le plus à perte politiquement
parlant alors c'est clairement la
majorité puisque c'est elle qui est au
commande au manette c'est Gérald
d'amanin il faut pas oublier que Gérald
d'amanin malgré un contexte
insécuritaire terrorisme très compliqué
bénéficie d'un crédit très fort chez les
Français en terme de volontarisme en
terme d'action c'est pas le sarcozi de
2002 2007 qui est resté quasiment 5 ans
place Bovo avec à part l'intermède à
Bery mais c'est l'idée qu'il essae de
changer des choses le fait par exemple
vous le savez qu'il publie tous les
jours sur son compte Twitter XX Twitter
la la le profil des quinzaines
vingtaines de personnes expulsé chaque
jour bah plaî sur le mode bah voilà il y
a vraiment des résultats tanges fait des
choses et c'est vrai que de par son
attitude et Arnaud l'a parfaitement
rappelé il rappelle le Emmanuel Macron
de 2015 celui de la loi Macron de
simplification pour essayer d'éviter à
tout prix le 493 parce que 1 493 sur le
papier c'est n absolument pas infamment
dans l'opinion publique c'est maintenant
synonyme d'un échec d'un acte
d'autoritarisme et du même si c'est un
texte soutenu par l'opinion oui par
l'opinion mais je passe de la scène
parlementaire il est il sera sans doute
rejeté par le RN sur le mode il va pas
assez loin par bien sûr la gauche nupes
et la gauche non nupes donc c'est vrai
que le 49 r doit être évité pour Gérald
d' pour créer cette distinction et
peut-être prendre date dans la
perspective d'un remanimement ou de 2027
ouais et et là on a l'impression qu'il y
a un petit jeu entre elliisabeth borne
et géralin parce que geréralin il dit
moi j'ai toujours fait adopter mes
textes en 493 sur un 493 ce sera le
choix de la première ministre Elisabeth
bande dans le Figaro hier matin dit
c'est à Gérald armmanin de trouver une
majorité je lui fais confiance on a un
peu l'impression que c'est le baiser de
la mort oui elle a raison de toute façon
parce que que je veux dire au moins elle
ne se surexpose pas elle a quand même
utilisé je rappelle près de 20 fois le
493 depuis le mois de juin 2022 dans une
séquence ce qui dans une séquence aussi
courte est certainement un record mais
je suis pas sûr que Al il faudrait voir
avec la période recard c'est 38 mais sur
plus de 3 ans ou c'est quand même sur
plus de 3 ans donc on est sur un trend
qui est en tout
cas est exponentiel c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire non mais si vous voulez
c'est vrai mais c'est en plus bon Géral
harmanin du fait de son parcours
politique je rappelle quand même que
c'est un ancien l'air et le plus à même
d'aller puiser dans ce réservoir de voix
qui permettrait l'adoption du texte 1493
mais le risque l'autre risque le dernier
risque c'est ensuite moi moi c'est la
question que je me pose depuis le début
depuis qu'on parle de ce texte autour de
cette table et ailleurs c'est que en fin
de compte que vont faire les
républicains les républicains ont
toujours dit que si l'exécutif dégainit
le 493 ils allaient déposer une motion
de censure donc là aussi si vous voulez
la motion de censure on en revient à la
question de la motion de rejet de tout à
l'heure est-ce que cette motion de
censure sera suffisamment agrégative
quelque part pour souder des oppositions
qui pour des raisons totalement
différentes décideraient de censurer le
le gouvernement donc peut pas la déposer
seul en plus cette motionou alorsair ne
peut pas la déposer seulle parce qu'ils
ont pas le nombre de députés suffisant
mais ils arriveront trouver quand même
les quelques députés qui leur manquent
pour pouvoir cossigner une motion de
censure en fait on peut l'imaginer en
l'occurrence iront-ils jusqu'au bout de
leur logique ça ça aussi c'est la la
question et ce sera à suivre et c'est
dans la revue de presse on va en parler
tout de suite avec
[Musique]
Quentin et content on en a parlé cette
interview de gerérald haranan dans les
colonnes de Nice Matin voilà très
rapidement je vous redis effectivement
qu'il est effectivement interviewé dans
dans ni ce matin je souhaite qu'on
quitte les postures politiciennes dit
Gérald hermanin qui refuse de se placer
dans l'optique d'un recours au 493 sur
le projet de loi immigration plusieurs
titres et votent la visite du président
de la République aujourd'hui sur le
chantier de not Notre-Dame de Paris tout
à fait nous sommes à 1 an de la
réouverture programmée de la cathédrale
ouest- France propose un reportage au
cœur du joyau gothique même chose pour
le le républicain Laurin qui visiblement
étit dans le même groupe de journalistes
qui a visité la cathédrale qui parle
d'un d'un chantier hors normes c'est à
lire dans dans ces deux journaux la
Provence revient sur l'idée de
l'uniforme à l'école oui alors ça existe
déjà à exonprence à l'ensemble scolaire
Sainte-Catherine nous dit le journal où
le modèle a fait ses preuves je cite et
d'ailleurs on sait que cette semaine
Gabriel le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a annoncé une expérimentation
à grande échelle de l'uniforme même si
le ministre ça vous partager sur cette
question Quentin c'est le weekend du
Téléton oui et de nombreux titres il
consacrent leur une ce matin le Téléton
créé en 1987 c'est une tradition chaque
autonne avec notamment les 30 heur de
direct sur les chaînes de la télévision
publique mais il mobilise surtout ce
Téléton plus de 200000 bénévoles dans
10000 communes en France et pour donner
on le rappelle c'est le 3637 où
téléton.f fa toutes sortes de défil
loufoc sont évoqués dans la presse une
farandole de centaines de personnes dans
Lyonne marathon de longueur dans la
piscine pendant 12h en Bretagne
l'édition 2022 pour rappel avait permis
de collecter 90 millions d'euros pour la
recherche médical en 2022 oua 36 37
évidemment on le rappelle alors c'est
vendredi on est au mois de décembre
c'est donc marché marché Noë marché de
Noël Quentin voilà c'est donc une
tradition sur publ sén les vendredi
matin surtout avec vous c'est ça en fait
on y revient effectivement à Monaco
puisque il a
été on est loin de de Strasbourg et de
l'Est de la France effectivement mais il
a été inauguré hier et il est il est
assez magique visiblement et il est sur
sur le port effectivement après de
Monaco il y a pas dans l'Est ça peut
être sympa aussi le marché de Noël à
Monaco merci Quentin merci beaucoupéri
Dav merci beaucoupous on se retrouve
évidemment la semaine prochaine merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi on vous
souhaite un très bon
weekend
[Musique]